hello and welcome to this video this is
a joke face from Denmark mm-hmm it looks
a lot like he's going for the classical
system let's do can I do something else
something something out of the ordinary
what did I do something like this we're
going five I guess but Matt's it appears
very flexible what is this they are 90
sound if i go to f-for what is he doing
we're really going to be six maybe yes
okay it doesn't look so bad huh I mean
interesting playing against the sea for
porn okay my cue to be three
I now switches to stone one very
interesting strategy okay now that makes
it make some sense it's absolutely
absolutely interesting so let's get rid
of the dark red bishop okay nights you
force probably coming hmm it's not
really possible to prevent I mean okay
it's not nothing fatal but would like to
prevent it if possible come here I go
around this lightship follow I might
have night takes d5 in this position and
night sea takes d5 85-95 not objectify
bishop is 6 we should take the foxy foxy
form hmm I'm not sure this works
let's see d 5 e 5 95 95 bishop divided
bishop is six arab chick see father roxy
for that should work so 95c 595 create a
four equally free is that working now I
can check on c4 so that should work
should work Jim other puzzle must have
Queen f7 or 26 but I can take the form
Jack there should be six as Roxy form um
Bishop c4 he might have roped a group TX
Queen f7 Roxy one social work may I
think it just not okay i'm winning two
points him for nothing in particular
yeah so Roxy for Bishop c4 Bishop c4 is
probably stronger if it is working in
the first place itself pen is a little
bit it might have Bishop takes root em
into gypsy for roxy foxy for Bishop to
g5 this is very very very very possible
very much possible okay and so I'll take
with the rook 55 does Roxy eight g8
Quincy for salsa winning it this is kyra
I think Bishop takes that exchange sack
and Bishop t5 it was potentially
dangerous or maybe not Quincy to Abbott
ok this is still I think pretty clear
solution okay check check okay so i can
grab another pawn yeah i think it's okay
i'm lots of covering see twosome doesn't
look like this okay check there's much
certificate II going on resins and a
real interesting interesting way of
playing that's all of a sudden md5 you
know I think black should be should be
ok here is Bishop on d 7 it's not
looking so great but it has this ideas
typical typical IDs from to go to 80 h
from then h5 or simply stay where where
it is and play against this pawn yeah
but he just has to avoid Nancy for this
just plain losers
yeah it does engine engine controls and
this is winning yeah he has to play
something else and there are many
options I guess you can home this is
them the engine move new g5 is possible
i mean i don't have any any attacking
pieces and here it is really just
winning yeah if it goes down i have a
look-see for now because this is a
fairly convincing win some chinese takes
and now Luke takes yeah I was briefly I
was afraid of this little bit this
there's this but I have Quincy to or 23
I have to prevent this no yeah I'm okay
he has to give the exchange I have to
take the exchange back but this rest is
was totally for him yeah here Luke f8
was necessary and then go back and i
have m three pawns up just have to avoid
any gross blunders okay well thanks for
watching